it takes a tough skin to be the leader
of a country even more so of a country
that basically did not exist until a few
years before you took power even more so
if that country is torn between two cold
warring bloc's located in an
arm-wrestling contest that will result
in total destruction and yet you still
managed to give the finger to both
factions and do your own thing this is
the story of the leader of post-war
Yugoslavia he kept together a federation
made up of six nationalities for 35
years he led the non-aligned movement
during the cold war years and he
survived the assassination attempts of
the most dangerous men on the planet
including mr. Joseph Stalin
so please welcome today's protagonist
Joseph Bros better known as Tito the man
who could not be killed
[Music]
yes at Bros was born on the 7th of May
1892 in the town of comb rivets near
Zagreb in modern-day croatia into a
large peasant family croatia at that
time was a part of the austro-hungarian
empire a patchwork nationalities in
Central Europe which had recently
expanded into the Balkans Europe was a
perfect example of this multinational
ISM being born of a kraut father and a
loving mother very little is known about
Europe's parents and his early schooling
actually even his birth date and his
real name are disputed this is really a
testament to the extent that this man's
life was shrouded in mystery this is why
we're gonna skip straight to his teenage
years and try and navigate as much as
possible the certain facts of its life
age 15 Joseph was apprenticed to a
locksmith in 1907 and in 1910 he
completed his training and started
working as an itinerant metal worker in
Austria and Germany it was around this
time that he joined the Social
Democratic Party of croatia slavonia and
dag Reb his first sign of political
engagement Joseph's life had changed for
good in 1913 when he was drafted into
the austro-hungarian army he clearly had
a talent for soldiering as he was
singled out for noncommissioned officer
training and by the summer of 1914 he
had become the youngest sergeant major
in that army of course the summer of
1914 was not a good time to be a soldier
or let alone an NCO
in the austro-hungarian army or well any
other army for that matter as the first
shots of World War one rang out Joseph
and his unit was sent to invade Serbia
facing an unexpectedly stiff resistance
but Joseph was a good squad leader and
in early 1915 he was transferred to
Austria Hungary's most important front
in the east to face Russia this was an
even tougher opponents in Vienna's
armies did not do well in general
joseph's experience with the
austro-hungarian army strengthened his
belief that it was not much of an armed
force it was ineffective in a real war
and merely an instrument of oppression
against Slavic nationalities and the
lower echelon of society on the 4th of
April 1915 Joseph's unit was overrun by
a cavalry charge this was the first
occasion in which young sergeant rose
proved that he was a tough cookie and
would not get down easily one of the
Russian cavalry men charged straight at
him but Joseph being a good
I was able to deflect his 2 meter Lance
and fight him off another cyrus soldier
though attacked him from behind and
pierced him close to the heart
now that could have been the end of this
story but yoseop survived albeit
severely wounded and was captured by the
Russians over the following two years of
hospitalization and captivity the once
social democrat became acquainted with a
much more radical ideology Bolshevism by
1917 he had been completely bought over
by the majority communist faction and
renounced any affiliation with Vienna's
armies in February 1917 the Tsar had
already been ousted by Kerensky's
moderate government which did not sit
well with the Bolsheviks nor with the
yoseop who actively participated in the
July days demonstrations in Petrograd
and in the October Revolution which
eventually brought Lenin to power when
the new Soviet government signed the
brest-litovsk agreements with the
Central Powers which left Russia out of
the war Europe could have easily
returned home but it tells something
about the steely character of the young
activist that he decided to instead join
a Red Guard unit in
Siberia to continue the fight in the
russian civil war against the
reactionary white armies following a
white counter-offensive yes it fled to
modern-day Kyrgyzstan but it was able to
return to arms can join the newly formed
southern Slav section of the Bolshevik
Party whilst getting married long away
finally in October of nineteen twenty he
returned to his native Croatia in the
meanwhile the austro-hungarian Empire
had dissolved giving birth to several
new countries in Central and Eastern
Europe one of these being the kingdom of
the Serbs craps and Slovenes later
better known as Yugoslavia upon
returning yoseop had joined straightaway
the Communist Party of Yugoslavia the
cpy he must have jinxed it because the
Yugoslavia mmediately banned all
communist activities the next three
years the cpy it went quiet as day
yoseop resuming work at a metal mill
near Zagreb
but in 1923 yoseop made contact again
with the cpy which had now gone
underground it seems like clandestine
activity was well suited to the young
metal worker as he thrived in the
communist organization he first acted as
a party functionary and
trade union organizer in Croatia and
Serbia until 1927 when he was promoted
to organizational secretary for the
Zagreb cpy committee his Kenya in this
office it attracted the attention of
Moscow and the Commons and the Soviet
sponsored organization of international
communism the Comintern rewarded him
with an appointment as the grebs
political secretary in 1928 after the
assassination of a crowd member of
parliament in June 1928 yes it took the
occasion to take the cpy out of the
shadows by staging street demonstrations
against the authorities but they reacted
swiftly yes its apartment it was raided
by the police where they found explosive
material proving his adherence to the
insurrectionary hardline of the
Comintern Broz was arrested in August
and sentenced to a five-year term but
the trial gave him a stage to voice his
convictions and gain credit with the
party authorities why yes it was in
prison Yugoslavia it was in Tamil
forever torn apart by the opposite
tensions of centralization versus
autonomy of its constituent nations and
autonomous provinces which by the way
are Sylvania Croatia Bosnia Herzegovina
Serbia Montenegro Macedonia Kosovo and
Voivod inna during this periods the King
Alexander the first established a
dictatorship - stemmed the nationalistic
aspirations of non Serbian population
the regime also cracked down on the
Communist Party by ordering the arrest
of most of its leadership the cadres of
the party they needed to be replenished
that is why when Rose was released in
March of 1934 the leader in exile of the
cpy Malan Gore ket's summons him to his
Vienna headquarters to give him a
position in the party's political this
was year tsipras taking his political
career to the next level from local
representative to one of the national
leaders it was also the occasion in
which he assumed his distinctive
pseudonym Quito from February 1935 to
October 1936 Tito moved to the Soviet
Union to work more closely with
Comintern and developed ties with the
Bolshevik leadership which would prove
useful in his climb to power in 1937 and
38 Joseph Stalin launched his campaign
of purges against political and military
leaders in the USSR which through the
Comintern extended
other communist parties across Europe
the CPI was not exempt and Gork ik among
others was executed according to Serbian
journalist Paris cements Tito actively
profited from the Stalinist repression
he took the occasion to spy or even
actively betray some of his comrades and
his friends thus painting himself in a
good light with the common zone he was
rewarded with a mandate to rebuild the
CP wise Politico with his hand-picked
left tens among them one mill of an Deus
whom we'll encounter again a little bit
later and of course the natural next
step was from Moscow to appoint him new
secretary general for the cpy by 1939
Tito's grip over Yugoslavian communism
was undisputed and he started laying
plans for the future of the country in a
clandestine conference in Zagreb in
October of 1940 Tito revealed his
strategy first leverage the 24,000
members of the party to launch an armed
insurrection against Alexander the
First's reign second established a
federal state USSR style to address the
ongoing issue of Yugoslavia multiple
nationalities the big occasion for armed
insurgency presented itself in
Yugoslavia's darkest hour in April 1941
the kingdom was occupied and partitioned
by the Axis powers mainly Germany and
Italy but also Romania and Bulgaria the
Yugoslavian theater during world war ii
was to put it mildly a confusing mess
which contributed to sowing the seeds of
emiti amongst its building blocks that's
gonna do my best to explain it here
after the occupation the main resistance
forced were the Serbian Chetniks of
dragula Mikhailovich loyal to the
government in exile and supported by the
Allies the cby had organized its own
parallel partisan network led by tito
with the multiple agenda of kicking out
the axis defeating the Chetniks and
taking over Yugoslavia to install a
communist regime other factions on the
other hand had started collaborating
with the axis mainly the Croatian
fascist party or Russia Tasha
in 1942 italian general mario rata also
known as the black beast was charged
with quashing for communist insurgents
to this end he sought and obtains an
alliance with the Chetniks
ideologically opposed to Tito's men
rotters seconds army and his
Technic auxiliaries launched a violent
repression not only against the
partisans but also civilian populations
in Slovenia and Croatia especially in
areas bordering Italy as an interesting
aside here while Roja was a total dick
to Yugoslavs he was actively helping
Jews escape from Yoshi Tasha and the
Gestapo facilitating that relocation to
neutral countries but the rest of the
Chetniks changing sides my allies
shifted their support from Mihailovich
to tito who was able to increase the
scale of operations leading a successful
guerrilla campaign the communist leader
was able to control most of Bosnia by
1943 even establishing an independent
government Tito by now had become such a
nuisance to the axis that Hitler took
direct interest he charged his most
effective henchmen with a secret mission
to locate and assassinate Tito and the
partisan leadership this henchman was
legendary SS commando Otto Skorzeny
already known by them as the most
dangerous man in Europe in February 1944
scuzz ne launched a two-pronged
offensive grounds forces were to
surround the identified location of
Tito's headquarters cave in the Bosnian
Mountains while the regular troops would
distract the partisan forces
Skorzeny would attack the helicopters
with his signature move a combination of
gliders and paratroopers but the Germans
had underestimated the cpy fighters they
put up a stiff and prolonged resistance
pushing back both prongs of the attack
and allowing Tito to escape to safety
both the black beast and the most
dangerous man in Europe that failed to
catch or kill Tito the governments in
exile by now had to admit that they had
to negotiate with this man in June 1944
the role of Prime Minister and XR Ivan
super-chic messed with Tito and agreed
to coordinate their activities to
complete the liberation of the country
but any hopes of restoring the monarchy
were quashed by the Soviet Army aided by
Tito's partisans in October 1944 they
liberated Serbia the last monarchist
stronghold as Germany retreated and the
fascist state in northern Italy
collapsed in April 1945 Tito's communist
forces extended their control to the
whole of Yugoslavia achieving total
victory by May of 1945 but Tito's
partisans didn't stop there taking
advantage of the Axis powers collapsed
they extended the national frontiers by
taking the Istrian Peninsula and
portions of the julian alps
territories that were disputed with
italy since the end of World War
1 the occupation gave way to brutal
reprisals which struck retreating axis
soldiers cravat and Slovene
collaborationists as well as Italian
civilians it is estimated that up to
15,000 people were killed many Thrones
still alive into the natural wells
typical of the region as the war ended
Yugoslavia was still a monarchy albeit
with Tito as Prime Minister but after a
major election victory in November of
1945 80 percent of the vote
Tito took full control of the country
exiled King Peter ii and declared the
republic although it would be fair to
describe this really as a dictatorship
his first years in power they were
particularly brutal in order to
consolidate his power tito started
purging in a stalin like way mahalo
votes the leader of the Chetniks and the
other opposition leaders they were
executed the archbishop of zagreb and
other members of the catholic clergy
were incarcerated tito then moved to
nationalize industry and undertake a
planned economy a plan which included
forcing small farmers to give up large
portions of their produce to the state
so far so good Tito is fashioning
himself as a bargain Stalin of the
Balkans but Tito and the big man in
Moscow they clashed when the Yugoslav
leader intended exporting his brand of
communism to Albania and Greece at a
time in which the official comment
online was very cautious in the spring
of 1948 Stalin started planning for a
purge of the cpy but Tito was able to
maintain control over his party of the
army and the secret police over in
Moscow Starling would not have a nyet
for an answer he disowned his old
comrade he publicly condemned Tito
expelled the cby from the Comintern and
economically boycotted Yugoslavia Tito
who was above all a pragmatist did not
shed tears over the rift with his BFFs
in Moscow and initiated a gradual shift
towards the West maintaining nonetheless
a political doctrine ecwid distance from
both in NATO and the Warsaw Pact inside
his borders tito tightened his grip on
power aided by a very effective secret
police these guys started cracking down
on fellow Stalinists and later on many
other dissenters many of whom up to 600
over the years would be tortured to
death in Tito's high-security political
prison Galia talk also known
as Devils Islands as befits such a
contradictory character
Tito also enjoyed the natural beauty of
a Paradise Island the Isle of Vanga in
the northern Adriatic this island was
home to one of his many presidential
residences since the one that he used to
entertain many political leaders from
Fidel Castro to Queen Elizabeth and
Persian Shah Raisa Pallavi Tito had a
soft spot for film stars too and
Elizabeth Taylor and Sophia Loren to
mention just two were among the many
actresses to pay regular visits now
before we continue with the story of
Tito's rule in Yugoslavia let me tell
you about some of the juicy details of
the rivalry between t2 and Stalin as you
may have guessed
Tito's move for independence from Moscow
had not made Stalin very happy it was
not only that it seems like Stalin was
also fearful and even jealous of the
Yugoslavia which made him consider the
serious possibility of having him killed
now that's an enemy you don't want to
have all those cause any may have been
the most dangerous man in Europe but he
was the Cookie Monster compared to
Stalin soon Lavrentiy Beria a head of
the NKVD was put on the case Stalin
spymaster organized no less than 22
assassination attempts against Tito
these included increasingly outlandish
methods ranging from your standard
weapons such as a rifle or a bomb and
then going into full James Bond
territory one attempt for example
involved an ornate jewelry box which
would release a cloud of toxic nerve gas
when it was opened my personal favorites
involves a Soviet agent called max
according to a secret memo max was
instructed to infiltrate a diplomatic
reception in Belgrade posing as a Costa
Rican diplomat Teodoro Castro once there
max was to release barriers most secret
weapon a lethal bacterial plague the
death of Tito and every other person in
the room would be guaranteed the memo
said max himself would not know anything
about the nature of the substance to
save his life max would be immunized
against the plague beforehand
luckily for Tito and indeed the whole
population of Belgrade Stalin's death in
March of 1953 meant the hit was called
off and Max was recalled to Moscow
speaking of Stalin's death that was a
stroke right well according to Slovenian
historian Jose Pierre Yvette's there may
be something
else behind it or rather someone else be
reverse claims that Stalin may have been
poisoned with potassium cyanide and that
the poisoning had been ordered by none
other than Tito in retaliation for the
attempted assassinations against him if
this is true it would be the fulfillment
of a famous note sent by Tito to Stalin
one which may well be the most badass
letter ever written it reads Stalin
stop sending people to kill me we've
already captured five of them one with a
bomb and another with a rifle if you
don't stop sending killers I'll send one
to Moscow and I won't have to send
another okay so let's get back to
politics as he moved westward also
Tito's internal policy started to Thor
towards a more liberal stance this was
mainly thanks to his deputy and chief
adviser Milla van Deus old chum from the
early days of the clandestine cpy
together they shaped a type of socialism
that would allow workers to manage
industrial enterprises and even share
profits which was a pretty liberal idea
like communist standards
Tito also relaxed many of the regime's
strict controls particularly those
affecting small farmers as a result
Yugoslavia became the most liberal
communist country of Europe the West
reacted by offering financial aid and
military assistance by 1953 Tito had
even signed a mutual defense pact with
Greece and Turkey which equated to an
informal association with NATO after
Stalin's death in 1953 by poison or by
stroke Diaz proposed further reforms
which would have accelerated the drift
towards the West most importantly to
give up the one-party system Tito
however rejected this proposal in
January of 1954 which led to a rift with
his trusted vice presidents and
eventually his exile Tito preferred
instead to explore reconciliation with
the new Soviet leadership under Nikita
Khrushchev who visited Belgrade in May
of 1955 the two leaders agreed on the
Belgrade declaration which committed
Soviet leaders to equality in relations
with other communist countries which was
a big step forward in formalizing at
least Yugoslavia's independence from
Moscow but in the following years
Khrushchev and his successor Brezhnev
happily wipes in their backsides with
the Belgrade declaration by crushing the
Hungarian Revolution in 1956 and then
the Prague Spring in nineteen
68 in both cases Moscow blamed Tito for
inspiring these dissident movements
which led against a frosty
Soviet yugoslavs disillusions with both
the west and the communist bloc Tito
eventually sought like-minded statesmen
everywhere and he found them amongst the
leaders of the developing countries
negotiations with Egypt and India in
June of 1956 led to a closer cooperation
among the states that were not engaged
in the east-west confrontation from
non-engagement Tito developed the
concept of active non-alignment that is
the promotion of alternatives to bloc
politics as opposed to mere neutrality
the first meeting of non-aligned States
took place in Belgrade under Tito
sponsorship and his guidance in 1961
[Music]
since the days of world war ii and
internal divisions exploited by the Axis
powers
Tito's big preoccupation on the home
front was to maintain the unity of
Yugoslavia this was the only way by
which the Federation could maintain its
independence from Moscow and its
increasingly limited reliance on the
West as Tito declared we have split an
ocean of blood for the brotherhood and
unity of our peoples and we shall not
allow anyone to touch or destroy it from
within
none of our Republic's would be anything
if we weren't all together but we have
to create our own history history of
United Yugoslavia also in the future but
Tito's concept of internal Brotherhood
was about to be increasingly threatened
by demands of decentralization in the
1960's and 1970's ironically it was his
big idea of workers self-management
which gradually shifted the balance of
power away from the central party
authority and from the federal
government the resulting tensions for
autonomy first in the factories then in
the provincial centers they opened
cracks within the cpy leadership between
1963 and 1972 during this period Tito
launched a second wave of purges first
addressing factions who wanted to
increase centralization of power and
later Croatian and Serbian liberals who
were calling for more autonomy in their
respective nations Tito's response to
the crisis of the 1960s and early 1970s
was the fashion a system of symmetrical
federalism supposed to establish formal
equality among the six Republic's and
Serbia's to Auton
Provinces Kosovo in the voivod inna
unfortunately this system while not
providing enough autonomy to the smaller
Republic's also annoyed the two largest
Serbia and Croatia that felt that they
were giving them too much autonomy to
put it simply tito trying to make
everyone happy and he managed to piss
everybody off
only Tito's prestige and his personal
charisma were now holding together a
very fragile Federation everyone in
former Yugoslavia now remembers where
they were on the 4th of May 1980 this
was the day in which Tito died of heart
failure aged 88 during his remarkable
life the leader always aimed to find a
balance a third way oscillating between
east and west communism and capitalism
peace and war Devil's Island and his own
private paradise his toughest balancing
act the one between centralization and
local autonomy eventually did not
survive eleven years after Tito's death
the former Federation disintegrated in a
lot of bloody battles and ethnic hatred
reminiscent of the war already fought on
those lands for decades earlier but
that's a story for another day
which I'm sure will tell you at some
point for now I really hope you enjoyed
that video if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos just like
this four days per week you can hit that
bell so you find out about all of those
also if you're looking for something
else from me why not check out my other
channel called highlight history I'm
gonna link to that below and as always
thank you for watching